yeah according to this software I am
life i dunno i hope i am give me a quick
information if I'm really live going to
start now playing some games we can look
at is there something great to watch
something going on or not nothing in
particular yeah at the moment there are
some strong players around murasa which
is playing a lot so I'm kind of
interesting to look at if there's
something to go but let's play a couple
of games myself actually I am really I
want to play some games I'm going to
love to play some blitz now because I've
been teaching all day and didn't play a
single game of chess so I'm really in
for something here playing kill Leon the
Italian I am Carlo de Moura yep I'm
going to play a double fianchetto he
knows something about it he has played
it himself quite funny ok he's going
with a 5 an interesting way to play but
i'm not sure about it in this particular
position i'm liking my position yeah I
can't play before yeah i think a three
bishops III that should be ok this pawn
on a three can be a liability it can be
irritating but also a liability ok I'm
going to put the Queen out here and then
go from there okay he wants to play you
five it seems all rights difficult
that's difficult to prevent maybe I
should take first now that the night is
on g7 this is gaining a little bit in
strength but
now if I've is kind of annoying if he
gets that in mad okay not much that I
can do is going to play you five um I
wonder if d 4 is a move d4r 495 that
looks okay maybe takes 94 also should be
okay so look it looks good okay he's
going to try to put this night on c4
yeah so probably not ft 7 is going to be
played
interesting I have an idea actually
night ft 7 can i play Bishop efore hear
this kind of tactic probably not hmm ok
but if he takes them I'm going to its
opening up the D file so that's
something that I don't mind there are a
couple of books on patterns and chess
there's a recent one by Dutch I am
Thunder all the way during that's a
pretty good book actually ok so let's
see i have to come up with an idea takes
everything here hmm that's not looking
that great at the end i don't really
have any great compensation yeah but i
don't want to take on this second that's
not looking good with a knight coming to
see four at the end yeah I don't know it
doesn't look really great ok it's not
going for that at all now I can actually
take a form de Queen f7 is this
something or is this crazy hmm it's my
it's probably crazy takes Knight takes
this Queen d5
we might play f6 but i can go night to
you three anyway hmm i don't really get
this what i get is that i'm playing too
slow but that's a kind of normal I maybe
can do 96 now hmm f6 Nyjah for me yeah
somehow this is not going too well maybe
I had some tactic but I didn't see it I
matched on the clock
huh I had sis it's not really nice he
can go here I am 95 that's really not
good I have to go all the way back not
very nice this position so what about
what about this that looks that sucks
this pollution f4f h maybe f1 very very
very ugly and maybe I get some kind of
activity you can also just ignore all
that like night c4 or something any
positional move will do that's really
ugly ugly stuff yeah he's not playing
because this is very it's very nice for
black he has a ton of good options
taking on a three I will try to play the
Kings in unitech got a request for that
yeah as I said it's a very ugly position
ok I'm going to try to at least make
sure h4 is not hitting yeah
yeah it's got something to see for its
really I have no I cannot do much it's
just very very ugly the only thing is
that it is relatively closed position i
might be able to hold on for a bit but
it's very very uncomfortable I just give
a giveaway deform yeah I don't know how
bad this is it was terrible before
I look at the questions quick after the
game I still try to fight him as bad as
this position is it really is bad so
look you won rooks e5e octi one maybe at
least he cannot play nights nights you
form how do I get activated may be here
my scotty for coming now not much that I
can do it just it's just far too bad
this position I completely screwed up
this this opening right after the
opening no that's really very little I
can do I cannot move the rook I cannot
move the night nice got rooked e6 I mean
I'm not even threatening anything
maybeee 494 is a little something now if
III 94 it's a little last kind of trick
which probably isn't even working but
it's okay he fought that one now it just
forgets just garbage this position wow
okay I have to resign him okay so um
that was a question let me let me check
what it was I actually cannot scroll
back now I have to I really need to play
a couple of games guys those kind of
questions a little bit much
there's a question is it hope happening
often that stuff exchanges to a draw in
e4 e5 openings as black hmm I'm not
saying that it is happening very often
but it's it's a scenario that sometimes
happens in those open games when when we
have to the two parties clashing in a
way and sometimes it leads to trades but
this happens in many many lines it also
happens in in the Sicilian for example
if you play something like the night off
you have very often sharp positions that
tend to simplify to two draws very often
even totally force drawers in that kind
so it it can happen yeah the last game
was terrible I admit that it sometimes
not so easy in those in those sessions
late Monday Jie because I didn't play
any warm-up game or something I'm kind
of coming right out of a lesson and have
to adjust to actually playing chess
which is sometimes against people who
have played them like for one or two
hours and a kind of in the in the thick
of things so we're going to see what
happens here we ever we had a budapest
gambit and yeah maybe f5 is a move now I
don't know hmm okay my rook on v1 and
the Queen and c2 are not ideally placed
let's see i'm not sure if f5 is a move I
need a little bit more coordination here
then then I'm in good shape ok I'm going
to put the Queen here ok 5 is a weird
move looking at those at this rook with
the Queen rd2 I did not see any game
today in a VAR a bottle or anyone and
anything I worked the whole day didn't
didn't watch anything
mmm nie Dage 3 is a sideline but not a
bad one um Kasparov said that the Scotch
is the only is the only alternative to
the Spanish Minh not sure it is an
interesting at least interesting one at
least because it's it leads to very open
and sharp position so there is some
point to that that opinion but of course
you can play the Italian game or
whatever I wouldn't say that the fringe
is the better opening to play for wind
and a 45 it's just in I mean it's maybe
a bit unlucky that you hit upon such
such a scenario there is some things
that are really a bit a bit boring when
II 45 is coming the four nights game for
example but okay this is just one line
and if you aware of it you can mostly
make sure that's not happening okay
after a look at look at this game okay
what is he going to not be 39 a four
it's got a very funky rock okay he did
not do something in that regard ok I
have f4 f5 here I want why not let's do
that this night doesn't really have any
great squares he can retreat and if I go
f5 now it's going to go to g5 so not
sure that's a good idea have to be a bit
cautious not to overextend this can
easily be over extension okay his rookie
mmm he's going to play a five made me do
him little strengthening move
I just can take b6 now right what is the
point I don't see it maybe we should be
six but Knight b6 looks good and dwell
d6 hangs and everything looks so very
shaky there's a question do I like
playing on chess.com um I mean it's okay
it's okay they really have they don't
have many people online that you can
play against this is a big problem if
you want to get a good game it's it's
just it's just better on icc that's just
the way it is okay I'm going to push
this open here right f5 i have e 5 so
that should be good yeah I did see
John's games against multicast it looked
like a very very strong player maybe it
really is magnus carlsen hard to say
okay I got an exchange sacrificed here
but I don't really see okay so he's
giving away he need another exchange ok
I'm going to take this first and then
take you form what do I want to play b5
mm-hmm yes b5 is pretty good opening up
the whole stuff yes i have a new chair
yeah it was not not only too noisy it
also was not very well functioning
anymore i had problems with my back and
everything and now i have an axle nut
shell maybe I should have done some
crowd funding for this chair yeah people
donate for my chair would have been an
interesting interesting thing
and this thing was actually so costly it
what it would have been okay but it is
really a very important um tool yeah I
really use it every day for hours so I
wanted to have something good ok I'm
going to play this one right this should
be ok d takes III Ruby aid and killed
he's in you in lots of pins now I really
should be a winner at the gymnastics but
is not a complete solution but and
thanks for the recommendation okay King
f7 hmm so I can take here right Bishop
takes rook takes Marquez taking them
Bishop g7 or the I mean I cannot and I'm
going to take him that's okay what now
Bishop b5 or what stay a quicker when
see six maybe no I be should be five is
good
I think if you are kind of outraged a
little bit if you lose a couple of blitz
games it shows that your arm a
competitive person and you shouldn't
read too much into that it's just I mean
being into it it's just okay shouldn't
maybe you shouldn't yell loudly or
whatever but I wouldn't worry too much
okay I'm going to check this night now
let's see what is going to do looks
difficult what idea is Queen 25 route 27
and I don't really see what he's doing
against that or C 6 and then it's got
the check so Queen d5 looks good
multicast played a few games of checkers
funny I can tell you a funny thing I
don't even know the rules of checkers I
know that's very uncommon but I don't
don't know them when I when I kind of
quit let's say simpler games like non
chess I really I really didn't look for
something else I just do chest and
that's it c6 looks looks a bit that
looks really nice going for c7 you got
top 10 wrong puzzles in a row on a
tactic trainer yeah I can I did this I
did once 10 wrong puzzles in a row on on
on chest tempo that was frustrating you
really feel like it completed yet but
it's just how it is it is difficult to
this game if it would be so easy we
would have stopped long ago
okay i'm going to promote am playing
super slow yeah I don't know why I mean
I'm never really quick but I'm even
slower than usual it's kind of ok it's
not even a check so I'm going to meet
him yeah that was a decent game after
after one point okay yeah check us is
still played out in the Indian
tournament for when I'm visiting in the
Netherlands which is quite often for
indie games they often have checkers
tournaments going in the same place
where um our chess event is taking place
so um it's still a popular game it seems
yeah John hi yeah just challenge me
right sure I just just just bring our
challenge I'm going to go into accept
okay after that I got I got one game
going here playing John column you later
but I had the five minute requests out
playing Alex this guy is always playing
the the London system and I'm going to
play an entire London hey Queens is
seven no Bishop f4 for you okay okay so
he's playing some aggressive moves here
on the queenside but the good thing is
he has to think a little bit for himself
now not relying on his typical London
setups going to fianchetto here and okay
he can play with c4 that looks kind of
kind of normal i'm going to set up some
kind of hedgehog structure
yeah John please challenge me right
after this game is over it will take a
while of course and after that we're
going to start this is quite funny
because I had exactly this position
exactly this position I had in round
three of the open bavarian championships
in bad visa a very amp and I wanted a
pretty nice game there and this guy is
playing quite similarly blacks idea here
is to play in a situation in a in a set
up without any particular weakness I'm
kind of sitting there solid and what I
want to do is finally do something
against this pawn on c4 so my trade my
aim is actually to trade some pizza see
him at the end John is John Bartholomew
this is Finn's 0905 he's also i'm having
a very nice youtube channel and he's
playing on the ISS he was a very very
high blitz bullet and whatever rating
and we are going to go on to play a game
after that is finished and then I'll do
this live come to him and he's doing his
this video for him for his channel so
you can see the can see double
perspective for this game yeah I traded
a bunch of stuff my idea is at the end
to play against ok Knight f6 or not
looks like a self-penned no I want to
want to use them the c-4 porn as a
target so let's see okay I'm going to go
to e6 and detect this pawn and let's see
how he defends it no it's not defending
it
kaneda what is what is the problem yeah
I'm greedy I always was let's take it
yeah tournament tournament of youtubers
an interesting idea of an old idea it's
probably not going to happen with all of
them because chest network is constantly
declining to play against anybody else
so we can do that but not with all guys
it's just like that okay um what is this
he's going to what if i play Queen f6
for capturing I can also capture right
away maybe do that and now I need to be
a bit cautious to not blunder stuff
maybe Queenie five yeah attacking h5 and
trying to trade yeah okay you right
Nicholas ocean bed also a candidate for
that I'm not sure that is playing on the
ISS here because its associated with
just 24 but I think it's definitely up
for playing
okay yeah I like this this is a nice
position if you text my a pound i have
Queen d12 a for Queen D 1 okay it's
there how do I do that Queenie to queen
e 2 nite a321 check King h2 is there a
way to cover all of it don't want to
give up the a pawn really it's a bit
inconvenient do I get to d7 somehow yeah
it's not not so easy technically what do
I do here a 787 arm attacked like to get
the airport now maybe start with this
kind of kind of unsure what to do check
HERE King up maybe e6 and then 95 95 is
not a problem okay let's start with this
then maybe e6 I cannot really I cannot
really keep them the a ponyo some bit
strange so be five and now then Queen d5
to keep stuff or queen d 30 that's an
interesting move if he takes Knight eggs
I cannot cannot preserve cannot preserve
this okay mmm that's not so nice and it
was surprisingly difficult this this
position or maybe I just play total
nonsense this is always a possibility of
course
but I really didn't didn't do well him
hmm yeah is ticking b5 very difficult my
night is just passive
not easy can I get can I get to his King
h5 maybe h5 h4 difficult okay h4 king
we're okay I'm going to play that first
and think about the details later I want
his King out okay it's taking okay that
I did not expect now is king is really
on the run so I can go here or queen f5
Queen have 54 let's have a look Queen f5
looks good yeah protects the night and
trends queen age five mate Queen g5
Queenie for check he has to play Queen
g4 I guess is something better I don't
see anything better g5 is this on check
not really
don't see when a direct win yeah g5
Queen takes Knight g6 check and wins yep
Wow and made next move yeah I needed to
be tricky yep it was difficult that
wasn't so easy I made it difficult I
don't know I don't know okay let's see
okay John I'm ready challenge me I don't
know I hope I'm open set open one yep we
play that's cool okay playing John the
following you here and we're playing a
5-1 game so it's five minute plus one
second of increment yeah so we're going
to see what happens one second increment
we both are doing commentary here and
okay I'm going to go i'm happy to play
amarok see bind if he goes for that no
he doesn't that means we probably get
some kind of benoni let's see what is
doing how are we going to transpose to a
benoni very early six it's that really
okay okay i'm going to test you then
that looks kind of fishy to be honest
isn't d6 a problem okay so we're going
to have a hand-to-hand combat here
Knight takes e4 his plan okay so Bishop
d6 okay 56 Knight takes e4 is the
problem if i play covering move like
Queen d2 for example he will castle but
should be six whoopty eight this kind of
thing I would really like to check on d6
because it kills his Catholic rights hmm
Queen takes Knight not working I don't
have something great down 92 is a move
but he will Castle night be three maybe
and good night before ah tricky tricky I
feel like I should have something here
it looks look strange but I don't see
what okay going to play went to play a
lame move at chickening out I know yeah
I think he's just going to cancel I
didn't didn't get it work get didn't get
it to work we should be six maybe I
spend too long on that probably
yeah I guess he will castle Bishop d6
route d8 this kind of thing and then e
five probably leads to mass exchanges
probably hmm
tricky yeah in terms of rating what you
should know where this is the Blitz
rating not the five-minute pool rating
those ratings are much higher john
hasn't has a rating of about 3,000 which
is pretty decent for him it could be
higher actually if you try it and I am
26 I'm sorry 2600 which is very low in
comparison but I simply never play this
time this time control this is a
challenge type of blitz and if I would
really put my put efforts into it i
could get to this kind of rating as well
a little bit lower john is the better
blitz player but I could be like maybe
100 points lower so but I never really
play that so i'm not i'm not really a
competitive I don't don't play that
something you cannot compare the ratings
very much okay mm-hmm I mean 95 this is
a weakness after all and Bishop d2 is
kind of annoying maybe so I don't know
if you can't just castle maybe you can
be should be to Queen a6 could be
okay castled so Bishop d 2 nite a queen
a 6 is not a problem is what he's saying
that might be true I was thinking that
Bishop g5 is actually quite nice maybe
not Bishop g5 Bishop takes pawn takes
Knight a for an ID before my I should do
that actually let's win a temple and
then see what he's doing Queen moves
okay and now I was thinking bishops III
as a good move yeah that's a good more
now he has to he has to do something
with this night I have a good position
here on c3 and I have ideas i have
ninety-seven at the right moment and if
he takes this is just going to be a good
structure for me i am ok going away okay
let's just do a good improving move so I
can take on c3 with the Queen what I
really like is that his queen is offside
while I have everything centralized this
is a position that can never be really
bad for white it always should be okay
and then my friends by might threaten
Bishop takes g7 him King takes Queen c3
it's nothing serious maybe but I have a
nice position here yeah John we have
played two games um enum in this dual
commentary format and I had a good score
I kind of I mean he's the better player
but I kind of do okay against him let's
see Ike i'm going to take here right ya
understand what he wants to do i'm not
sure that it's working though
I can give this check now and then he
has f6 and he has to play and he wants
to use the dark squares but is this
really possible right to deform let's
check first he has to play f6 I guess
and now 95 is a month 94 then
I can play Bishop b2 it's threatening
Bishop f3 though this is something that
I have to have to consider maybe just go
back this is easy and good night before
I played before and have a good position
i think or night b3 is actually also a
decent move OS 92mm so f three nights ok
this I didn't think about it all
interesting hmm that's an interesting he
wants to get the Queen back into the
game I don't want that let's avoid the
trade 95-93 which is quite good for me
and this night here is really out yeah
I'm may be threatening f 3g for trapping
it it's very close
very it's a very tricky position to play
it looks simple but it's not he has some
strange pieces maybe I could have taken
a five and then go h3g form maybe HP
Bishop is six maybe hmm I didn't really
think he had this kind of slowish move
so 83 bishop is 6g for Bishop g5 takes
Knight e5 for a tech here I see okay
great to play for before I know why I'm
very I'm really relaxed here timewise
but 20 seconds 20 seconds is not much
but this is increment and with increment
I tend to be I tend to be very relaxed
about this just saying that I'm able to
do some quick moves and not lose on time
17 seconds but one second increment the
night is still out there 33 is able to
take okay
he might have f5 in some at some moment
I'd play for f4 and then central
breakthrough I know he has his pawns it
is this will be a very very sharp
business now something in my kitchen is
ticking that's not fair ah that's not
fair and I blundered III ok ok I'm going
to I'm going to resign yeah right I can
resign I lost track there that was an
excellent position for white probably a
winning one at some point not easy not
easy at all I was I'm pretty sure that
was very nice for white I don't believe
in this kind of scattered pieces but I
have certainly missed chances there I
don't really i'm not a huge expert in
analyzing in this software which I don't
use so often I think we have to around
here there should be the key to to a
wide advantage pretty pretty sure about
that what is the comp saying night be
three wins here might be three what did
I actually play so this one is winning
Queen d8 f3 bishop is 6 and g4 because
here I just retreat and I'm winning a
piece so that was it ok what can you do
but it was an interesting game probably
a.m. there was more than one situation
where he had something my position was
better coordinated but I lost track them
ok what do we have here let's play a
couple of more of those poor games
getting some different opposition's
different opponents sorry ok well make
sure to check out John's channel yeah
he's posting this video as well so we
got to see his his view
of this game he probably also will do
more analysis then I'm doing I'm i
really don't don't know it I mean this
is a software that I don't use that
often and I don't really know how the
analysis works there I can't do some
basic things but I'm not the kind of I'm
not really good with those arrows and
stuff in this software okay new game
whose arm and what let's do something
else let's play e4 for a change let's
see an open the Syrian for a for a
change and I'm kind of conservative here
going to prevent Bishop before which is
a bit of a lame approach but it's not
that terrible let's get going here and
hope i'm not totally wiped out by
someone who knows this opening better
which is not a it's not very tricky
because i have no idea going to play in
kind of standard sicilian fashion here
Queenie one and things like that
okay let's get the king in the corner
I'm trying to swing the Queen to g3
getting something going on the Kings
side okay he's playing hooky it Bishop
f8 may be coming it's not so clear what
my plan is I have to admit that taking
and e5 maybe but that also that's also
not super convincing but I really don't
know what else there are moderators but
what is this cursing guys this is not
really on this is a chest sir we're kind
of civilized people here right ok five
so I'm going to drop back takes Bishop
takes to take these six you can get
affordable i get these six typical
complicated Sicilian struggle ok i'm
going to take and maybe put the night to
d5 or Bishop g5 also it is enough and
now 95 that looks kind of good right
what is he doing now rube d 6 i'll take
I it's going all the way there ok so how
do we play here c 3 or can also take for
Bishop f4 that's not doing that much
you six not helping c3 is going before
probably but anyway
i'm using i'm using the Blitz and
software because this is what I CC uses
for them for those um photo shows it's
just kind of the standard thing to do
okay it's it's only okay just that I
don't know I well I don't really know
how to analyze in the software it's just
I should check this at one point but I
never got around to it okay I'm a
technical this rook and I'm trying to
use my pawns let's see can I use my
pawns if I play d 6 mm not really maybe
I can can prepare that I can play
Knightly for now I what a shame I forgot
about 94 totally oh not good not good at
all there should be a man icc person
there to moderate them moderate the chat
down let's see what do i do here i would
like to place you form if he takes it
looks you one now that's a good pin so
let's set this pawn in motion okay I was
thinking that rook see one would be good
isn't it okay he's just giving away his
his stuff here surprising so let's see
it's still not that easy he's got some
material um yeah and where to go with
the rook not so easy it's not so easy of
course I'm satisfied with the Queen but
it's not like I'm winning very easily
at least I'm not so sure how to do it
Bishop to be three as good this is a
good square he has rupees and two pawns
that's not not exactly minor
compensation that's actually quite okay
hmm okay attacking f7 yeah it was an
interesting game John definitely I've
certainly had some advantage but it's
not not easy at all who's tricky to play
how do I do this here maybe rook see one
or something yeah blackest is nicely
coordinated this is not easy here I use
my my active my active pieces h4 is not
on and this is attacked the b2 porn is
attacked I don't know i don't have a
clear web player I'm not ever not having
a clear way here yeah blackest black is
okay in this position pretty sure about
that a question is can I I mean this is
I really cannot really do much in terms
of active play I have this half this
pressure against f7 which makes
difficult for him to do something but I
really cannot do much at all
that was a bad idea I should have stayed
on I should have stayed on f7 but ok
probably cannot do much 93 oh I'm sorry
oh I'm so sorry guys uh-oh who are you
you you ok haha that was bad I stumbled
right into that but I mean I couldn't
win yeah he was kind of hanging on it
was probably a draw at the NTS maybe
even better because it's easier to play
ah but running right into that ah oui ok
let's I need one ethnic one more game I
need a win yeah that's not good give me
a win give me a win yeah that was
probably I've got Goldman yeah this is
Graham master loosed him off that's a
cool opponent very strong gem and let's
see I'm going to play my repertoire my
bogo kind of stuff let's see what he's
doing do I play d6 cannot forget my own
book but i do right hey this is how it
is played b5 and we go from there Black
is putting his stuff his paws on dark
squares dark squares Bishop c1 is a good
move now I did lose some weight a little
bit I'd like to move who's poor but it
takes time ok yeah that's an interesting
very interesting kind of position here I
kind of screwed up the move on a little
bit I didn't need to play Bishop c5 that
early on and now this is slightly
awkward a little bit
not a huge problem but it's slightly
awkward in precise move order mmm yeah
yeah for 95 mm
I totally totally screwed this this move
on up I hate that making it so easy for
people that's a very bad position a
really bad position Bishop c5 is just
terrible terrible this question about my
reviewed game series no no that's not
going to stop I'm just doing it on and
off i'll post some games and something
else it's kind of a mixed mixed bag this
is a regular feature of course um yeah I
really hate this position it is just bad
okay totally totally screw the move on
up look at this yeah the bishop on H 6m
amazing ah let's see what I can do here
if I would at least have the pawn back
on a 7 I could care so long but of
course even that is not possible it's
remarkable what I did here so let's see
we are going to Castle shorty anyway
maybe I can I don't know what Bishop
will come to F form rock t 8 is also
kind of bad looking maybe I can still
play that one Queen afore i have rook g4
stuff now it's ugly that would be nice
to bend the spammers actually yeah thats
it's really bad when we screw this up
Bishop c5 was very stupid more
yeah is yes to move the Queen but where
it's not so I mean it's a he has a very
nice position in any case but it's not
so easy to determine where did you go
kind of surprised that you takes that
long however okay i wonder if i have
some something in particular available I
mean he took really a long time can I do
this then h5 this kind of thing he has a
three before and then I go to be six
sites rubbish anyway you have to hope
for mercury in any case maybe i can get
rook takes root chicks in or something
let's do this first I have to do this
anyway and maybe I can play rook g4 and
then take take it well problem
might irritate him not not much but it
might yes I know I know buddy this hangs
yeah not much I can do you can just take
here a few months yeah okay he can you
can take can take on the form I don't
mind what a bad position it really sucks
it really sucks
I have zero compensation
yeah I know it just it just lost to me
sitting on on tons of weaknesses and no
compensation I came going here and
Bishop e3 okay is there some kind of
idea some kind of idea from me not my
queen doesn't have many squares right ah
what a game okay where is this bloody
resign bun wow that was bad yeah I
couldn't really I couldn't really ever
recoat from this opening I played Bishop
c5 with this which is really bad i have
to cast me of course Bishop c5 yeah then
night b3 that was really a bad idea I
had to retreat to here and then I'm in
this business with night a for
threatening and Bishop g5 threatening it
was really a totally miss played opening
really bad okay I go work for one more
game I really want to win one there was
a really bad really bad serious is that
good chess life in göttingen I really
don't know the name of the book is
called opening repertoire names in
bovania yes this is the book name yeah
the name is pretty much said unless them
publish things of something genius and
wants to change it it's not really my
title at some was it fits into a series
that they have of opening rapid to our
books so
so Michael Myers yeah I'm going to beat
that guy let's do it Michael Maya sets a
guy from halloween right and he is peace
dangerous yeah with the hockey mask guy
so we have to be cautious but I'm going
to try to win this game come on you want
to be quick for a change hopefully yeah
III really never saw that move Bishop d7
do I have to move the Queen again
probably but the bishop is not great on
d7 anyway the hockey mask guy is Jason
hmm that isn't the helloween guy also
having a hockey mask hmm I'm confusing
horror movies okay yeah Michael mind
they said that was this dreadful remake
right by rob zombie this was really bad
i remember that was kind of angry back
in the cinema when I saw that one the
original one was was a dis funny with
Donald Pleasence but ok Michael Myers
has a wide plain mask I guess you're
right I guess you're right
yeah now we have a Queens gambit type of
position cards but and I have a really
it's a nice one and I like this very
much it's a very convenient position I
ever he has a somewhat we admire on c6
which not really belongs there it's not
the end of the world but it's nice okay
it's going to regroup and I'm going to
do this typical attack thing here the
minority attack let's see how to do this
I want to try to prevent a trade here of
light squared bishops this I managed he
might play Knight age form from an
attack no he doesn't okay oops I'm sorry
so I can go to c5 going to do that the
96 is of course a good place yeah he has
a good place for this noise for this
night
night only six is nicely positioned
covers b7 my jump to e4 to see form yeah
that's nice yeah good advice I just
should have a beer and play gambit hmm i
can try with the gambit I don't have any
bien seems like a mistake I recognized
that already not having any be around
okay let's try for b5 b5 yeah but he's
got this Bishop here only six nicely
keeping things together yeah I played I
played the Kings gambit once in a while
for fun and yeah but it's difficult this
is the last game for tonight yeah people
recommend guinness as a BF yep i
subscribe to that i like Guinness
Guinness is good i am i watching the
walking dead i watched the first um the
first the first season actually and then
I kind of quit not that I didn't like it
I'd actually did um I did like it but I
I don't know what it was something else
grabbed my attention so I didn't I did
lost i did lose track a little bit there
I really did there are many many good TV
series around there's there some that i
really don't really get ya some like
Game of Thrones as simply people love it
and I understand in a way why my problem
is just that I'm absolutely absolutely
not capable to keep track of all the
people I just I mean there are so many
so many characters I lose track okay you
went c5 let's see
I was I was planning to play Queen a
three for this for this for this pin but
that's not that great actually he can
take b6 Bishop g4 maybe Bishop g4 Roxy 6
check it's not leading to much I don't
at least I don't see that it needs two
much takes rook takes Queen eh check-in
age 7 home I don't see anything here
probably I'm missing stuff it looks like
it actually looks like there should be
something at least something a little
bit I don't see it guess not my kind of
day I didn't see anything radium do you
see anything great I don't see it ok
taking and just yeah in German we have
an expression which is kind of
translating literally too yeah baking
small small chunks of bread yeah this is
kind of what I'm doing here really just
being satisfied with very very little ok
satisfied is wrong i'm not satisfied yet
it's just that i didn't see anything
great let's see maybe i can gain a
little bit of space here and go from
them I wonder is Queen before something
that gives me something prolly not right
can take and play three okay maybe I
actually generate some play on because
I'm allowing stuff h5 is a move but it's
not that's not super dangerous really
King may be here just centralized h5 is
not not something that worries me unduly
I have some good I have a good activity
with the Queen can go to f4 for example
okay Queen f for now maybe now it
doesn't lead to anything let's just get
the King up if he trades now King takes
this is actually as an advantage g5 I
wonder takes King F for this g5 check
maybe I play this first you can go g5
though this is this is probably the good
the good move that keeps it equal 5 and
I just saw it unfortunately i move the
queen is going to check me on a 3 have
to play this he's going all the way
around here I'm even worse I managed to
screw this up amazing f6 king is 6 King
see 50 ah wow that's embarrassing what
an embarrassing session Kings you won or
not k i'm going to resign that wow that
was bad okay sorry god this was a really
bad
a really bad session I was I just wanted
this was really stupid you know he went
here and I wanted here Bishop c4 I just
have to play g5 here of course and I
mean okay I'm never worse yeah amazing
that was really bad he can go here and
then I play whatever I can never lose
because of this this is king position
him wow that was bad yeah I really have
to wrap up the stream here like 11 hour
that's it not not more we already am
like 10 minutes above that so I hope you
enjoyed it anyway it wasn't a really
great performance but it was some
interesting games I mean at least you
saw how an IM can lose kind of kind of
bad games ok I hope you enjoyed it I'm
back next week I hope to join to have
you join me again for for a new session
then thanks a lot for watching I'm back
then bye